show me show me your medals guys
fantastic fantastic many many
congratulations to you both
um lauren to you first of all um
you know it is really interesting that
that you know you came to taekwondo
really quite late how do you feel about
about
hitting this medal when it wasn't even
you know your first discipline you you
know you you've got medals
in boxing yeah so um it was kickboxing i
was previously a kickboxer for 10 years
made the transition to taekwondo back in
2013
through the fighting chance initiative
which is actually open now
and they obviously ask athletes from
other sports to come and try taekwondo
and
see how they do and fortunately i was
good enough to
make the transition and yeah i've never
looked back since i've gotten a medal
olympic medal on my neck hey and and it
wasn't
you know we we spoke to um uh you know
um beth shriver's parents just a short
time ago and she was talking about you
know funding
being an issue her mom for you too you
know
as is often the case lauren families
have to make an enormous sacrifice don't
they in order to
to help somebody get to this point
apparently your mum gave up work the
pair of you lived in a caravan for a
while
um what does this mean to your family
that you've won this
yeah oh the absolute world um my family
we separated when i was
13 or 14 my dad stayed in wales my
mum came up to live with me in a caravan
in manchester and
unfortunately we weren't funded at the
time either so we went through that
financial struggle too my mom used her
inheritance and
they really did pump everything into
making sure that i could make this dream
become a reality
and fortunately i've paid them off not
with the color they'd like
but they're definitely proud of me
anyway and this is a medal for
the whole family and it's not just me so
well it is you know it's your first
olympics you know steady on
there's possibly lots more to come um
bradley let's move on to you now many
congratulations as well
um you know how how do you feel about
the last few days
i think it's been good to actually be
back um back in manchester
and the parents and all the rest of the
family the old metals at the airport
what was amazing i think
as a team we are amazing we strive for
greatness but we all were all
disappointed obviously
we could have the three people who
meddled were all within the last seconds
of going on to winning gold
what was what's a disappointment but i
think coming back
your parents don't have that
disappointment it's nothing but proud
being proud be having that pride of you
and they're just
happy that we've achieved our dreams
being able to go to the olympics in the
first place but actually coming home
with a medal
and then actually coming home and seeing
that it's
helped you bring be proud of myself it's
helped myself to be proud and then
actually realize what i've accomplished
because it is hard isn't it you know
normally in the olympics you'd get to
stay out there and enjoy it but because
of covid you're all having to come back
within 48 hours
and bradley you talked a little bit
about disappointment and i know that
she's your hero as well lauren jay jones
you know going out really quite early
did bradley did that affect the team i
mean
you know somebody who is such an
important part of the team and somebody
so
who's who a lot of people's hopes were
resting on
um i think at that moment obviously it's
obviously disappointing for all of us i
said
we're here we are a team not just a team
we're a family
not just the athletes the coaches but
the support staff so we win together we
lose together and we do take them losses
to her it's not just a job for anyone is
a passion
but obviously for me i'd take it or
obviously i would disappoint her for it
but i still had a job to do that day
i hadn't even had my first fight so it
was great for martin as well like
obviously not great in the situation but
being able to great for me how he'd be
able to switch because he was coaching
us both so
he couldn't keep that lingering he had
to cut that off and focus on me and
obviously after we can
reassess the situation and obviously
it's disappointing for
disappointing for the rest of the team
as well and bradley what about funding
um i mean
have you have you struggled with funding
over the years
um i think yeah definitely in the
obviously coming through cadets juniors
peewees because until you become
18 in the senior program everything's
your um
the parents obviously i was my mum's a
single parent so everything was just
down to her and then
it takes to go abroad and get the
experience you need
costs a lot to cost grands a year and
then
our sports aid was amazing it helped me
um
different awards throughout the years
and i also got the back in the best
award the year before i came into the
academy
but yeah without without my mum i won't
be here today
putting that financial investment into
me and then
i'm just glad that i'm at a place where
i can help pay it back
bless you lauren lauren do you think
that that taekwondo
will hopefully get more funding as a
result of this and that you know the
fact that
that you know it is coming more into
public prominence you you saw it at rio
um but but you know it has been a
struggle for you
yeah i believe um not just this games
but the last games as well we've
we've got incredible athletes um well
present and coming through the program
really so
i think the success of this games
definitely has helped to boost the
profile taekwondo i couldn't quite
believe how much interest
you know we had and how much support we
had it's been amazing so
hopefully it's the start of a very
exciting future for taekwondo and
hopefully we can keep bringing medals
back for great britain
and bradley you said you'll you'll see
me again in paris
um are we going to be be seeing a lot
more of you in the in the coming
uh competitions and the next olympics
yeah i think um we've shown we're here
with me and lauren both were not just
mixed in mixing with a bunch we are at
the top level we are at the top end and
our athletes to watch and my goal hasn't
been completed of winning gold at the
olympics so it's pushing i think
we just need to get tech under more
coverage at normal competitions because
the how we've put the performances down
as a nation in taekwondo
there's a lot of people who've been
inspired and want to join and
but it's just can can be a bit awkward
when the next time they can watch who is
in paris 2024 but
we've got the europeans in manchester
next year what'll be that'll be shown
live
so it's a lot of opportunities for
people to watch it again and get behind
us
fantastic stuff well listen uh i'm gonna
ask you to do it again just because
you know we don't get to see them very
often show us your medals
fantastic thank you both so much well
listen many many congratulations and
it's lovely to talk to you both and
congratulations to your families too as
you say
it's it's down to the families who
really really put in the hours thanks a
lot
thank you fabulous